من القدس ينضم الينا الشيخ محمد حسين مفتي
القدس وديار الفلسطينييه شيخ محمد اهلا بك
ما الذي يعني بالنسبه لكم هذا الاقتحام
الذي بات الان ذا صبغه رسميه مع توالي بن
كثير اذا وزاره الامن القومي
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
المسجد الاقصى اكثر من مره ولكن هذه المره
هو يقتحم بصفه رسميه حيث انه وزيرا للامن
القومي الاسرائيلي وبالتالي هذا يعطي صوره
واضحه لانه هناك توجه لدى هذه الحكومه
اليمنيه المتطرفه هذه الحكومه التي تتشكل
من مستوطنين ويدعمون الاستيطان ويدعمون
الاستيلاء على الارض الفلسطينيه ويدعمون
كذلك محاولات السيطره على المسجد الاقصى
المبارك باتمام المخططات الاسرائيليه
رانيا الى فرض واقع جديد في المسجد الاقصى
وتغيير الوضع القائم
والوصول الى التقسيم الزماني
والمكانين للمسجد الاقصى يعني هذه الحقيقه
هذا الاقتحام وهذا الاعتداء واعتداء
واقتحام رسمي يمثل الحكومه الاسرائيليه اذ
لا يمكن ان تتم مثل هذه الاكتحامات وهذه
الاعتداءات من قبل وزراء في الحكومه
الاسرائيليه او اعضاء في الكنيست
الاسرائيلي الا بموافقه واضحه وصريحه من
قبل الحكومه الاسرائيليه ورئيس هذه
الحكومه وبالتالي جاء هذا الاتحاد وهذا
الاعتداء من قبل ابن جرير على المسجد
الاقصى في صباح هذا اليوم الباكر ضمن هذا
المخطط للحكومه الاسرائيليه التي لم تعد
تخفي نواياها اتجاه المسجد الاقصى
ومحاولات فرض واقع جديد في المسجد الاقصى
بعد ان فشلت كل المحاولات السابقه
للمساس بالمسجد الاقصى او بالمساس بالوضع
الديني التاريخي القائم في المسجد الاقصى
المبارك ولذلك لا يستغرب حقيقه من قبل هذا
الوزير الاسرائي المتطرف كما لا يستغرب ان
ياتي هذا الاقتحام مؤيدا من قبل الحكومه
الاسرائيليه ايضا متطرفه واليمنيه في هذا
الوقت بالذات وفي بدايات تشكيل هذه
الحكومه التي وعدت طبعا احبابها ومنتخبها
بتحقيق بعض الاهداف لهم ما عاد يخفونها
وبخاصه فيما يتعلق بالمسجد الاقصى
كالتقسين الزماني والتقسيم المكاني بل
الاقتطاع جزء من المسجد الاقصى وتحويل هذا
الجزء الى كنيس يهودي الى غير ذلك من
الممارسات والطقوس الدينيه التي نعد
يخفيها لا الوزراء ولا اعضاء الكنيسه
الاسرائيلي كما لا يخفيها بالتاكيد
المستوطنون وافراد جمعيات الهيكل المزعوم
الذين ينادون صباحا مساء بتغيير الوضع
القائم في المسجد واستباحه المسجد الاقصى
المبارك امام كلها المتطرفين وكلها هؤلاء
الذين يحاولون ان يحققوا اهدافهم واحلامهم
في المسجد الاقصى المبارك بالتاكيد نحن
نقول وبشكل واضح المسجد الاقصى نعم تفضل
شيخ محمد حسين يعني
فضائل فلسطينيه قبل قليل كما تبعنا في
مؤتمر صحفي نقله مباشره ااه اعتبر ذلك
مستفزا هذا التسلل اللي بنثير المسجد
الاقصى اعتبرته صعيدا خطيرا واستفزازا
اللي همم الفلسطينيين وللامه الاسلاميه
كافه وقال بان هذا الامر ينذر بحرب دينيه
ماذا ما المقصود بذلك
هو بالتاكيد
لو هو بالتاكيد يعني هذا استفزاز واضح
كل الفلسطينيين بما نعم نعم بما فيهم طبعا
الفصائل الفلسطينيه طبعا سبق ان هددت
الفصائل الفلسطينيه بان اي مساس بالمسجد
الاقصى المبارك هو يعتبر تجاوزا لكافه
الخطوط الحمراء في المسجد الاقصى وانا
اعتقد بعد ان يقوم هذا الوزير الذي هو
وزير الامن الاسرائيلي القومي يقوم بهذا
العدوان السافر على المسجد الاقصى
بالتاكيد هنا التجاوز لكافه الخطوط
الحمراء التي اعلنتها الفصائل واعلنها كل
ابناء الشعب الفلسطيني وايضا يجب ان يعلن
هذه التاكيد كل الامه العربيه وكل الامه
الاسلاميه لان هذا تجاوز نعم بخطوط
العقيده في المسجد الاقصى المبارك هذه
العقيده التي تمثل بالتاكيد جزءا من عقيده
كل مسلم في هذا العالم يعني حينما تكلم عن
المسجد الاقصى ونتكلم عن حرب دينيه كما
سرتح عبد الصمد ما في شك يعني المساس
بالعقائد الدينيه والمساس بالشرائع
السماويه والمساس بالمقدسات الاسلاميه
بالتاكيد هذا يدفع الامور في منطقه متفجره
اصلا وفي منطقه يعني غير مستقره اصلا
بالتاكيد يدفعها الى حافه المخاطر وربما
اذا ابتدات مثل هذه الحرب الدينيه الكل
ربما يعلم متى تبدا ولكن بالتاكيد لا احد
يستطيع ان يتكل بنهايه هذه الحرب الدينيه
لما لها من مضاعفات ولما لها من مساس همم
واضح
ومساس همم فعال باتجاه العقيده واتجاه
تحريك هذه العقيده في نفوس اصحاب هذه
المقدسات يعني نحن حينما نتكلم عن المسجد
الاقصى نتكلم عن عقيده او جزء على الاقل
من عقيده كل مسلم في هذا العالم نتكلم عن
حضاره كل في هذا العالم نتكلم ايضا عن
المساس بالقوانين والعراف الدوليه التي
كفلت بشكل واضح كفلت حمايه اماكن العباده
وحريه الوصول الى اماكن العباده لاتباع
اصحاب الدين المتعلق بهذا المكان وهو هنا
في المسجد الاقصى
اتباع الديانه الاسلاميه والعقيده
الاسلاميه والحضاره العربيه كل هذه الامور
مجتمعه بالتاكيد تدفع بالامور الى حافه
المخاطر وتدفع بالمنطقه الى حافه عدم
الاستقرار تماما التي هي اصلا منطقه
متفجره وقابله لهذا التفجر الخاصه حينما
يتعلق الامر بالعقيده ويتعلق بما كان
العباده ويتعلق بجزء من عقيده كل مسلم في
هذا العالم لا يمكن بحال من الاحزان ان
يقبل ابناء الشعب الفلسطيني عموما ولا
يمكن ان يقبل ابناء المنظمات
سيئات والجمعيات
والفصائل الفلسطينيه بكل هذا العدوان على
المسجد الاقصى المبارك بارك الله فيك شيخ
شيخ محمد حسين مفتي القدس والديره
الفلسطينيه من القدس المحتله شكرا جزيلا